some of the Insidious things that they
do the Chinese regime and the Intel
apparatus understood the importance of
of uh
regulatory uh decisions right
regulations here in the US and the
impact that would have on things like
mining right uh or Agriculture and so as
an example they're not trying
necessarily well they are but it's not
they don't consider it the most
important part they're influencing local
communities they're influencing local
politics state politics at that level
right to make decisions about about
regulations um phosphate phosphat is a
good example it's a very good example
right you like food you like large scale
agriculture to feed the world better
have some phosphate right it's
fertilizer so um leading producers of of
phosphate China uh Morocco Russia you
know just they they're up there but
so the they understood if if we go in
and we impact local community decisions
about you know access to phosphate
mining right and they and and we promote
or we encourage you know through a
variety of ways right supporting local
activist groups supporting uh operations
that you know that they're more on
National basis that try to do
environmental concerns right they're
trying to do good things right the these
activists in the environment they're
it's not like it's nefarious and they
say if we could just cut a deal with the
Chinese regime but the Chinese regime
understands us and so through a variety
of cutouts they're able to support these
groups and next thing you know whether
it's down in Florida you know with
phosphate or it's anywhere else you know
towns or city councils are saying no we
don't want that you know we don't want
we're going to have to do something
about that shut it down that's an
enormous benefit to a country that is
the you know key producer of that
mineral why don't we go to the Far East
then because Taiwan just had elections
they looked pretty legit I mean people
were actually holding tickets and there
were people checking things and it all
kind of seemed like oh that's how it
could work in functioning democracies uh
but there's a big situation going on
with ch China Taiwan Independence are
they seeing American weakness etc etc
I'm just kind of hand no you're right
you're right uh it it was a tidy
election it was a tidy election and they
they sorted it out and they were able to
call it you know didn't take a month
um yeah but um yeah the the the problem
from China's perspective is that the
wrong party won right so they were they
were pushing there were basically three
parties and and they were contesting
this but there were only two that were
seriously contesting it and one was the
the Democratic um people's party the DPP
and the other was Quan Tang party and
the quman Tang party uh is very much in
favor of closer relations with China
China was very much hopeful that they
would win they didn't the DPP won uh the
vice president of the DPP became or of
of the government became the president
the new president William Li and um
they've been fairly vocal about the
importance of taiwan's Independence and
now that that word means a little
something different right when you talk
to the Taiwanese people they can be Pro
we want Taiwan to be independent and
free they don't mean
you know rattle the cage and be
completely separate you know from China
they still believe in the importance of
that relationship right so we sometimes
think about it and go okay they're going
to have a revolution and declare their
independence and everything it's not
really what they're talking about but
even having some space between the idea
of reunification uh or basically Beijing
taking over Taiwan um that is something
that x uh xiin ping won't won't counter
so he doesn't he doesn't want to hear
that so does it matter in a way what
happens in their elections I mean I know
at least temporarily it's good for the
Taiwanese people of course to be a to
express themselves but ultimately if
China wants Taiwan it's going to take
Taiwan at least at least with this admin
American Administration something like
that yeah yeah I think that they've um
the calculation is more about
um it's not so much about who's in the
white house as how long is xingping
going to staye of China right um I think
he
views U the reunification idea bringing
Taiwan back into the fold uh as his key
Legacy so I think if you could magically
figure out when he's going to finish up
being you know sort of this iron fisted
ruler of China then you could say okay
between now and that point in time in
the future that's when something's going
to happen and I don't think it's going
to be uh you know military they don't
want China doesn't want have to worry
about a military takeover and they've
talked about this sort of the the soft
approach and we you can kind of see what
they did with Hong Kong
right that was accelerated and helped in
part by the pandemic right we were all
over here looking you know at this and
and uh and they kind of stamped out the
last vestiges of democracy you know
during that time and it happened right
now that's a little bit different right
you know in a sense because you know
Hong Kong was always sort of temporarily
leased sort of right there was always a
sense that it was going back right and
and so it's not quite the same but they
brutally Stamped Out the Democracy
movement there and so I think you know
their their view on Taiwan um despite
the fact that there's almost no distance
you know in the straight there between
the two uh is they don't want to do it
militarily and and I think um you know
they are intent on doing it they've been
very clear particularly during the past
year she has made some very clear
statements that it is inevitable is what
he's saying and so yeah the Taiwanese
people look at that and go you know and
there's some that that want that
reunification you know but uh you know
the
majority want things to be essentially
the way they are right and it sort of
seems like if they think Trump's coming
back in a year they might want to
escalate that the speed of that right
that's what what G might want to do
there could be that calculation but they
play a longer game you know we take
everything in very small bite-sized
chunks and that doesn't typically happen
in in China you know they they play
whether it's this sort of issue or
whether it's an intelligence operation
or anything they play a real long game
you know so I I don't think we want to
read too much into just a change in
administration what what does generally
sane China policy look like to you like
I think people hear what you said about
Iran and it's like you can sort of like
make sense of in your brain it's like oh
there are weapons in these places there
are trade routs being shot at there's
people being murdered that's not how we
look at China China is doing a lot of
other things related to technology
related to releasing let's say like
there's some other stuff but it's a
little more Tick Tock it's a little more
Amorphis versus just like military
stations in countries right Tik Tok is f
people talk about Tik
Tok the Chinese regime would never allow
their children to have access to Tik Tok
right they have a different um WeChat
right you know uh which is a cleaned up
version right so it's not on my phone
it's on that guy's phone over there oh
and told him he didn't have to do it but
he wanted to yeah um but but what do you
what is like sensible policy related to
all that related to like an information
War that's happening to our young people
I will say that one of the things that
that um that the previous president that
Trump did um you know and you love him
hate him right you know he's he's has a
personality he's not my cup of tea I
lived in New York for a long time people
in New York who had a chance to watch it
he's a he's he's a tri-state area
developer that's where I'm from yeah
exactly so you know you get punched in
the nose you punch the other guy in the
nose I mean it's people there knew what
what was happening and what the guy was
going to be like nobody thought he was
going to suddenly become a sophisticated
you know thoughtful individual who was
going to be presidential that you know
but one of the things that he did that
was very smart and I think very useful
was to elevate the the conversation
around China right and to put a
spotlight on just how much damage the
Chinese regime and their Intel apparatus
has done over the decades right in ter
of theft of intellectual property the
cost of that to us and to our allies to
the West um and just the outright theft
of research and development right um
fenel I mean fent fenel yeah I mean it's
yes so that's that's a whole separate
you know Counter Narcotics issue that
you know but um the it's their it's
their intelligence operations it's their
economic
Espionage um
those things have done uh damage that we
can't even calculate the cost of over
over decades in terms of lost
opportunity lost jobs um lost um you
know uh revenue streams they could have
you know supported and built up other
countries other businesses they're
incredibly aggressive um and then you
know what what they've been doing while
we again kind of get focused in one area
whether it's Iraq Afghanistan
um domestic concerns whatever it might
be we have a hard time it seems uh
multitasking and again that with their
sort of their longer view they have a
strategy and so they they've spent a
couple of decades now traveling around
the world people for the most part know
about this belt and Road initiative that
that China has but they've been going
around locking up as an example uh
locking up uh Mining rights right in
South America or in Africa um for for
key minerals right critical and rare
earth minerals um and it's the critical
minerals that are really more important
I I always thought we call it rare earth
and people think well those are the
important ones you're thinking well it's
more really the critical minerals
they've been locking up uh those
opportunities right they have a monopoly
on processing of of key minerals that
we're never going to get to 100% you
know Green um because we don't have the
ability to process much less mine but to
process and refine those those minerals
for things that we need such as I don't
know batteries right and so you hear
this talk about you know uh Battery
Technology and how we're all going to go
in that direction and that's great we
should be doing lots of different things
right for energy but the Chinese knew
that years ago and they had a plan and
they've been doing this
um and they also do other things they do
things that are more Insidious than just
going around and cutting deals right
usually it's in a sort of a Usery
situation where the the country finds
out that they're doing a deal with that
country then finds out a few years later
that they're completely in debt can't
afford the loans end up having to give
up more right um but the some of the
Insidious things that they do the
Chinese regime and the Intel apparatus
understood the importance of of uh
regulatory uh decisions right
regulations here in the US and the
impact that would have on things like
mining right uh or Agriculture and so as
an example they're not trying
necessarily no they are but it's not
they don't consider it the most
important part they're influencing local
communities they're influencing local
politics State politics at that level
right to make decisions about about
regulations um phosphate phosphat is a
good example it's a very good example
right you like food like large scale
agriculture to feed the world better
have some phosphate right it's
fertilizer so um leading producers of of
phosphate China uh morocc
Russia little you know just they're
they're up there but
so the they understood if we go in and
we impact local community decisions
about you know access to phosphate
mining right and they and and we promote
or we encourage you know through a
variety of ways right supporting local
activist groups supporting uh operations
that you know that they're more on
National basis that try to do
environmental concerns right they're
trying to do good things right the these
activists and the environment they're
it's not like it's nefarious and they
say if we could just cut a deal with the
Chinese regime but the Chinese regime
understands this and so through a
variety of cutouts they're able to
support these groups and next thing you
know whether it's down in Florida you
know with phosphate or it's anywhere
else you know towns or city councils are
saying no we don't want that you know we
don't want we're going to have to do
something about that shut it down that's
an enormous benefit to a country that is
the you know key producer of that
mineral so that's something that they do
and that that and I I'm I've been
fascinated by that because it shows
again it shows this Long View and from
an operational perspective sometimes the
problems with the CIA is that we we tend
to have a shorter view right we're
Americans and so that's just a tendency
and so our operations tend to have a
shorter time frame concern right um we
don't sometimes think about putting in
the the hard work of 10 to 20 years or
25 years to develop an asset right or to
develop a program that's going to
eventually produce results if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop screaming check out our
politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell